The answer is that that
algorithm is simply too slow.
It would have to consider all n
choose m possible bases, which,
for problems of any reasonable size,
is impractical.
All of the other suggested
problems really aren't problems.
Every feasible solution is
considered because we consider
every possible basis.
It's fine to consider
just basic solutions,
as argued in the fundamental
theorem of linear programming.
Indeed, the matrix B that we
generate here might be singular, but
we can just ignore that combination
as the algorithm does here.
And indeed, x might be degenerate,
but this is okay,
it would just show up in
more than one iteration.